[MUSIC PLAYING]
So normally, when you fly a
kite, you care about the kite
and not so much the string.
But in my research, I'm
interested in the dynamics of
what the line is doing, whether
it be a kite or a
tethered balloon, offshore oil
and gas platform underwater.
There's cable dynamics in lots
of different engineering
systems, anything with cable
moving around in the sky.
You have changing tension
along the line.
You can get things like
travelling waves.
And that's what I'm
trying to model.
Even in a simple system like
this - this is just a bathroom
chain and a shower ring - you
can get really complicated
things going on.
So if I just put the ring on the
chain, so it's just free
to fall off the end like that
- I'm just going to put it
back on - you can get
complicated things going on.
Because if I just drop
this ring...
No!
Failure is a part of life.
...it gets stuck.
So you see that and
you wonder, well
how does that work?
And its to do with the
tether dynamics.
So if I have this chain and
this ring falls, I get a
travelling wave going down
the chain like that.
So when this ring is falling,
it goes down the chain.
And there's a wave following
it down the chain.
And when the wave gets to the
end, there's a whiplash and
this ring is going to fall into
that hole and get stuck.
So you can see that you can get
complicated things even
just on a short length
like that.
But when you have something
that's longer - a balloon
tether out in the environment,
you have this long tether -
you can still have these
travelling waves going down
the length of your cable.
There you can see that
wave travelling down.
You're going to have
changing tension.
So the tension at the top,
because of the self weight, is
a lot higher than the tension
at the bottom.
And not only that, if this
is outside, you're
going to have wind.
So you're going to have
drag on this tether.
And you can imagine that
normally you have tethers that
are circular in cross section,
so something like this.
And in terms of drag, it's
really surprising that the
drag on this circular cross
section is actually equal to
the drag on this air foil.
So you can get a huge benefit
if you can streamline the
section in terms of drag,
which will decrease the
tension on your overall
system.
So my research has to do with
if you do change the cross
section of the tether,
will it be stable?
Can you even design something
that would work?
So I have an aerodynamic tether
here, and I'm trying to
model whether this would work.
So I have this tether, and I'm
going to discortise it into a
bunch of tiny sections.
So I'm going to break it
up into small chunks.
And that way I can model the
elasticity, and damping, the
bending, torsion, all
of those things.
And I can also model the
changing parameters up the
length - say this
is 20 kilometres
long - into the sky.
So I'm going to have changing
air density,
changing wind speed.
So I have a computer model
to model that behaviour.
But not only is that important,
the actual cross
section of the tether is also
important in terms of stability.
So if I draw this cross section
out, I have a bunch of
different centers.
So on this air foil I'm going
to have a centre of mass, a
centre of tension, a shear
centre, which has to do with
bending, and the aerodynamic
centre, which is
where the lift acts.
And depending on where these
centres are with respect to
each other, is going
to dictate whether
this cable is stable.
So I have this 10 metre long
length of the cable - of
aerodynamic tether.
And manufacturing this is
a project on its own.
And you can see that this one
this is the very first tether
that's been manufactured
and it has some
imperfections in it.
You can see there hasn't
quite filled in.
So it's just it's just a first
attempt, but I think would be
quite good fun to string this up
on a kite and have a go at
flying it and see
what it does.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now pull it tight.
You want to hold it?
You want to hold it from here?
Oh, no!
GoPro rig has descended.
So now we have the aerodynamic
tether section attached to the
kite line flying up there.
And you can see that it alters
the dynamics of the entire
kite system quite a bit.
This particular section isn't
really manufactured in any way
that it should be stable.
It's just an extruded
piece of something
aerodynamically shaped.
So it does flutter around
in the wind.
It flips.
And those are all of the
problems that you could
encounter if you'd had something
that wasn't stable.
But when it goes under tension,
you can see that it
sort of straightens out.
And ideally, what you want to
manufacture is something that
you've played around with the
cross sectional properties so
that it does the align
itself with the wind.
So going out and flying kites
for a Ph.D. might seem like a
bit of a laugh, but this
is the part that
makes a good film.
What doesn't make a good film
is me sitting in front of a
computer doing a bunch of code,
or me writing out a
bunch of equations.
But that stuff's really
interesting for me, and it's
those equations that dictate
whether something like this,
or an aerodynamic tether
would be stable.
And by the end of my Ph.D.
hopefully I'll have a better
idea of whether you can make an
aerodynamic, stable tether.
I think I might need
some help first.
Still recording!